und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und dunia
Hayali schönen guten Abend und gerne
hätten wir die Sendung heute mit etwas
positiven begonnen konkret mit der
Rückkehr der Basketball Weltmeister aber
leider reih sich gerade ein Katastrophe
an die nächste nachdem ja vor wenigen
Tagen die Erde in Marokko gebebt und
mindestens
2900 Opfer gefordert hat haben nun
heftige Unwetter im Osten Libyens auch
für tote verletzte und vermisste gesorgt
das Rote Kreuz schätzt diese auf über
10000 Christian Kirsch über ein
Bürgerkriegsland das nun auch noch gegen
Wassermassen
kämpft Wüste unter Wasser im Osten
Libyens erstreckt sich eine
Seenlandschaft dort wo es eigentlich
kaum regnet erst recht nicht jetzt am
Ende des Sommers mit gnadenloser Wucht
ergießen sich braune Schlamm und
Wassermassen in Dörfer und Städte die
Menschen nachts überrascht im
Schlaf das Unwetter verwüstet den Osten
des vom Bürgerkrieg zerrissenen Landes
besonders betroffen die Stadt darna hier
mündet ein seltenwasser führender Fluss
der wadidana den zwei Dämme zähmen
sollten sie brachen marode wie die
gesamte
Infrastruktur nach Jahrzehnten des
Bürgerkriegs in
Libyen jetzt gleich die Stadt lange eine
Hochburg des islamischen Staates einem
Trümmerfeld zerstört in einer Nacht hier
herrschen derzeit die Truppen des
Rebellen Generals hafta sie sind
überfordert mehr als 2000 Tote allein
hier
es sind ganze Straßenzüge sagt der
armesprecher die ins Meer gespült wurden
auch ihre Bewohner hüf hoch steht hier
das Wasser ganze Wohnblocks wurden
mitgerissen nach intensivsten
Regenfällen Hilfskräfte sieht man hier
kaum die verfeindete Zentralregierung in
Tripolis bot Unterstützung an doch der
Krieg steht den Helfern im
Weg
Flüsse wie der wadidana sind eher
steinerne Rinnen katastrophale
Hochwasser bislang extrem selten aber
vor allem im Winter
möglich das liegt daran dass die Böden
schlecht Wasser durchlässig sind dass
Niederschläge in der Regel auch schon
sehr sehr intensiv fallen in dem Fall
noch mal ganz besonders intensiv und mit
großen Regenmengen und das das
einsuggebiet von widana relativ groß ist
auch das ist für die Entstehung starker
oder sogar extremer
Hochwässer stark begünstigend
über dem östlichen Mittelmeer saugt sich
seit mehr als einer Woche das Tief
Daniel mit extrem warmem meerwasseroll
bei bis zu 29° Wassertemperatur jetzt
zieht der Sturm nach
Süden 10 000 Menschen so das Rote Kreuz
werden hier mindestens vermisst die Lage
bleibt unübersichtlich ohne Strom ohne
Telefon ohne Internet heute bat die
Zentralregierung um internationale Hilfe
wo es geht bestatten sie jetzt ihre
Toten für die kommenden Tage sagen
Meteorologen weiter starken Regen
voraus keine guten Aussichten der Osten
Libyens braucht also Hilfe leichter
gesagt als getan in einem
Bürgerkriegsland das weiß auch Wolfram
Lacher Experte für Libyen von der
Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik und
damit einen schönen guten Abend nach
Berlin guten Abend Herr Lacher wie
konnte es denn zu dieser wirklich
enormen Katastrophe jetzt kommen nun der
Grund für das Ausmaß der Katastrophe ist
ja der Bruch dieser zweier Dämme
oberhalb von Dana und dazu muss man
wissen dass die Infrastruktur in genau
dieser Region um Dana schon zu Gaddafis
Zeiten stark heruntergekommen war
Gaddafi hat damals die Stadt dafür
bestraft dass in ihr Aufständische die
Waffen ergriffen hatten in den 90er
Jahren und nach Gaddafis Sturz
2011 wurde dann jahrelang im ganzen Land
überhaupt nichts mehr in Infrastruktur
investiert in den letzten Jahren floss
etwas mehr Geld aber das ging eben unter
anderem in die Taschen von
milizenführern und
kriegsprofiteuren das heißt also es
handelt sich nicht einfach um eine
Naturkatastrophe sondern um ein Ereignis
das sehr eng mit der politischen
Situation in Libyen verknüpft ist und
dazu kam jetzt eben auch noch dieser
starke Regenfall es hat seit 40 Jahren
nicht mehr so doll geregnet die
Überflutungen sie begann ja am Sonntag
hat die Regierung im Osten um Warlord
hafter denn mittlerweile überhaupt einen
Überblick nein also bei der Regierung im
Osten handelt es sich eigentlich eher um
eine Fassade die hat keinen eigentlichen
Regierungsapparat konnte sich deswegen
auch äh kein schnelles Bild von der Lage
machen geschweige den
reagieren diese Regierung existiert im
Grunde vor allem äh um der Regierung in
Tripolis die Legitimität streitig zu
machen wenn wir jetzt über Hilfe
sprechen wie kann die denn überhaupt
aussehen auch die internationale Hilfe
wer kann die koordinieren sie haben es
ja gerade schon beschrieben staatliche
Strukturen gibt es eher nicht wirklich
und Geld da weiß man auch nicht wo es
dann ankommt ja also staatliche
Instanzen die wirklich hier
Katastrophenhilfe effektiv leisten und
koordinieren können die gibt es im
Grunde nicht wie gesagt die Regierung in
Tripolis gibt zwar Geld im Osten aus hat
dort aber keine wirkliche
Autorität wer dort das Sagen hat ist
general Chalifa hafter mit dem wird sich
internationale Unterstützung sicher auch
koordinieren müssen denn er kontrolliert
die Häfen die Flughäfen die Straßen in
dieser Region aber in darna ist hafter
für und seine sind seine Kräfte für
massive Repression und Korruption
berüchtigt und umso wichtiger angesichts
dieser schwierigen politischen
Konstellation ist es natürlich das
schnell
effektiv Hilfe geleistet wird von außen
interessant ist ja dass jetzt selbst der
Ministerpräsident der verfeindeten
Regierung also im Westen Libyens Hilfe
angeboten hat was bedeutet das oder was
kann das bedeuten ja also die beiden
rivalisieren Regierungen hafter und
andere Protagonisten in diesem Konflikt
spielen schon seit Jahren ein sehr
zynisches Spiel sie versuchen die Krisen
in Libyen nicht zu lösen sondern aus
ihnen Profit zu schlagen und das muss
man eben auch in diesem Fall befürchten
man muss befürchten dass es ihnen vor
allem darum darum geht als die die
hilfsbringer dazu stehen die öffentliche
Meinung zu
beeinflussen und weitaus weniger darum
tatsächlich auch etwas konkret zu le
isten und es wird mit Sicherheit auch
darum gehen die großen
Geldbeträge zu verteilen und zu
unterschlagen die die Regierung in
Tripolis schon jetzt für darna
bereitgestellt hat interessant ist ja
auch dass die Türkei und Katar die im
Bürgerkrieg auch eher zum besten
gehalten haben auch Hilfe jetzt
angeboten haben in der Not Rücken
Menschen und Länder offenbar zusammen ob
immer uneigennützig sein mal
dahingestellt Herr Lacher vielen Dank
für das Gespräch heute Abend live hier
bei uns im heutejournal ich danke Ihnen
und wir wenden den Blick jetzt weg von
Libyen hin auf ein anderes Land das auch
eine Katastrophe verkraften muss nach
Marokko wo vor vier Tagen in einigen
Regionen die Erde gebebt hat und damit
beginnen jetzt auch deine Nachrichten
Hanna ja denn dort schwindet mit jedem
weiteren Tag immer mehr die Hoffnung
noch Überlebende des schweren Erdbebens
zu finden dennoch haben die örtlichen
und internationalen Rettungs trups auch
heute ihre Arbeit unter Hochdruck
fortgesetzt dabei versuchten sie zudem
weiter in entlegene Bergdörfer
vorzudringen die Zahl der Todesopfer
stieg laut der marokkanischen Regierung
auf etwa
2900 zudem wurden mehr als 5500
Verletzte
gemeldet das EU-Parlament hat nach
langen Verhandlungen für schärfere
Klimaziele in der EU gestimmt die
erneuerbare energienrichtlinie wurde mit
400 70 zu 120 Stimmen angenommen bisher
war das Ziel bis 2030 eine einen
Erneuerbaren Anteil beim
Energieverbrauch von 32% zu erreichen
nun liegt das Ziel bei
42,5% zum Vergleich zuletzt betrug der
Anteil rund
22%. zudem sollen Genehmigungen
beschleunigt werden etwa beim Ausbau von
Solar und Windenergie die Richtlinie
muss noch von den Mitgliedstaaten
gebilligt
werden Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat
eine Äußerung des Palästinenser
Präsidenten Abbas als zutiefst
antisemitisch und erbärmlich bezeichnet
konkret geht es um eine Rede von Abbas
von Ende August in der er sagte dass
Hitler die Juden getötet habe weil sie
mit Wucher und Geld zu tun gehabt hätten
auch und 200 palästinensische Akademiker
Künstler und Aktivisten stellten sich in
einem offenen Brief gegen die Aussage
von Abbas daran verdeutlichten sie dass
sie jegliche Versuche n Verbrechen zu
verhamlosen
ablehnen die Vorwürfe sind nicht neu und
ein Fehlverhalten konnte dem
US-Präsidenten bisher nicht nachgewiesen
werden dennoch erklärte der Vorsitzende
des
US-Repräsentantenhauses McCarthy heute
Ermittlungen zur Aufnahme eines
amtsenthebungsverfahrens gegen Joe Biden
zu starten Hintergrund sind
Anschuldigungen gegen beiden an
illegalen Geschäften seines Sohnes
beteiligt gewesen zu sein das weiß Haus
wies die Ankündigung als politisch
motivierten Schritt zurück Aussichten
auf Erfolg hat das Vorhaben ohnehin kaum
im Senat haben nämlich die Demokraten
eine knappe
Mehrheit wer an long covid erkrankt ist
soll künftig einen leichteren Zugang zu
Medikamenten bekommen das ist eines der
Ergebnisse eines runden Tisches mit
Experten und Betroffenen im
Bundesgesundheitsministerium ausgewählte
Medikamente sollen laut
Gesundheitsminister Laubach auch
außerhalb der Zulassung verordnet und
bezahlt werden können zudem will sich
Lauterbach dafür einsetzen dass die
Gelder zur Erforschung von Long covid
von 40 Millionen auf mindestens 100
Millionen aufgestockt
werden wenn alle 15 Richter des Obersten
israelischen Gericht zusammenkommen dann
muss es wirklich um etwas elementar
wichtiges gehen denn das gab es so
tatsächlich noch nie und der Anlass ist
auch höchst end es geht um die DNA einer
Demokratie es geht um die
Gewaltenteilung
Ende Juli hatte die israelische
Regierung ein Gesetz verabschiedet dass
die Justiz massiv schwächt so hat das
Oberste Gericht aktuell z.B keine
Befugnisse mehr Entscheidungen der
Regierung zu kippen die es als
unangemessen einstuft sollten die
Richter dem Gesetz wirklich zustimmen
sich also selbst beschneiden eine
schicksalshafte wie historische Fr Frage
vom ersten Prozesstag Michael
berunge der Oberste Gerichtshof im
Herzen von Jerusalem ein Gebäude fast
noch prominenter als die Knesset das
Parlament gleich gegenüber alle drei
Staatsgewalten prallen heute im Gericht
aufeinander Exekutive und Legislative
gegen Judikative es geht um die
unerhörte Frage ob Regierung und
Parlament sich einen rechtsfreien Raum
schaffen die rechtliche Prüfung von
Entscheidungen einschränken dürfen ja
sag der Vorsitzende des
Rechtsausschusses von den religiösen
Zionisten nein sagen verschiedene
Antragsteller das hebble die
Gewaltenteilung aus eine Richterin will
wissen ob die Knesset dann auch einfach
das Wahlrecht für arabische Israelis
aufheben könne oder wah nur noch alle 10
Jahre ansetzen alles ohne richterliche
Überprüfung doch selbst nach diesem
Vorhalt bleibt der angesprochene dabei
und attackiert die Richter ein
oligarchisches Regime oder eine Gruppe
von Einzelpersonen egal wie intelligent
oder klug kann nicht einfach Gesetze der
gewählten Volksvertreter
annullieren für die Juristen der
Gegenseite nichts anderes als ein
Putschversuch man muss kein Experte sein
um zu verstehen dass diese Regierung
keine Ahnung von Gewaltenteilung hat
vielleicht wollen sie die Monarchie
einführen oder eine
Diktatur ich weiß nicht welche Art von
Regime sie wollen aber ich weiß sicher
dass wir uns m in einemreich
dagegen demonstrieren seit Monaten jede
Woche über 100000 Menschen auf der
Straße heute nur wenige Demonstranten
Pro und Kontra vor dem Gericht aber die
Gesellschaft ist so gespalten wie noch
nie das Oberste Gericht hat sich
Befugnisse angeeignet die eigentlich der
knesse Zehen ich denke es beansprucht zu
viele Befugnisse für sich und spaltet
dadurch das
Volk das ist ein demokratisches Land das
Gericht ist das oberste Gericht und
natürlich werden wir uns jeder
Entscheidung unterwerfen die es trifft
und wir erwarten von jeder Mann in
diesem Land allen Entscheidungen des
Obersten Gerichtshofs zu
gehorchen genau das wird die regierende
Koalition nicht tun haben verschiedene
ihrer Mitglieder bereits angekündigt in
einem Land ohne geschriebene Verfassung
in dem das Oberste Gericht als
Verfassungsgericht fungiert ist das eine
Kampfansage zwar ist mit einem schnellen
Urteil nicht zu rechnen aber
Verfassungsjuristen schließen den
Zusammenprall der Staatsgewalten nicht
aus wir werden wohl nicht gleich morgen
oder kurzfristig den Konflikt erleben
wer verhaftet wen aber das könnte in
Zukunft geschehen und ich hoffe dass
alle Behörden wissen dass sie die
Rechtsprechung des Gerichtshofes zu
respektieren haben und dass auch die
Regierung an das Recht gebunden ist und
dass alle Behörden des Staates einem
Urteil des Obersten Gerichtshofs
gehorchen
werden nicht nur die Prozessbeobachter
ein ganzes Land blickt diesen Moment im
Obersten Gerichtshof sorgenvoll
entgegen und ein Richter sagte noch
Demokratien sterben nicht auf einmal
sondern in kleinen Schritten und einer
dieser Schritte ist die Einschränkung
bzw Auslöschung der Pressefreiheit dort
wo Regierungen bzw Diktatoren keine
andere Meinung zulassen bringen sich
Journalisten und Journalistinnen allein
schon dann in Gefahr wenn Sie Kritik
üben manche lassen sich dennoch nicht
davon abhalten und bezahlen mit
Gefängnis oder aber auch ihrem Leben
andere wiederum flüchten ins Exil gerne
ins Deutsche Exil doch auch bei uns
steht die Medienfreiheit unter Druck
wenn auch aus anderen Gründen von der
ersten Hamburger Woche der
Pressefreiheit Sven
ren Personenschutz für einen
Friedensnobelpreisträger es braucht
nicht viele Bilder um zu verstehen dass
Dmitri murathof nicht auf der
offiziellen Gästeliste des Hamburger
Rath Hause steht russland hat den
ehemaligen Chefredakteur der
Oppositionszeitung novaja gasetta als
feindlichen Spion eingestuft er muss
Anschläge fürchten wie weit die Zensur
in seinem Land geht erklärte auch am
Beispiel einer Künstlerin aus stankt
petersburg sie schrieb in einem
Supermarkt peace also Frieden auf die
Preisschilder an den Regalen jetzt sitzt
sie im Gefängnis und ist sehr krank
ekatharina glimann würde zu Hause wohl
auch längst im Gefängnis
sie ist die stellvertretende
Chefredakteurin der novaja gettea
europausgabe sie lebt seit d Jahren in
der Schweiz als
exiljournalisten einige aus unserer
Redaktion arbeiten noch geheim in
Russland versteckt sie arbeiten unter
einem Pseudonym wir anderen wissen nicht
mal wie die Kollegen heißen oder wo Sie
sich aufhalten das weiß nur der
Herausgeber wir sind schon ziemlich
isoliert in Deutschland und der Schweiz
so sagt ekatharina gliegmann lebe man in
sicheren Hefen doch auch diese Hefen
sind stürmen
ausgesetzt
mikrofongen Übergriffe gegen
Journalisten die wir hier
Personenschützer brauchen Hetze in
sozialen Medien offene oder verdeckte
Anfeindungen gibt es immer wieder und
offensichtlich immer mehr auch
hierzulande Deutschland liegt im
internationalen Vergleich der
Pressefreiheit nur noch auf Platz 21 die
Gefahr sehe ich sozusagen unter der
unter der Oberfläche brodelt es das
Misstrauen gegenüber Medien die verbalen
Angriffe und irgendwann geht da eine
gewisse Grundlage unserer liberalen
Demokratie
verlorenünda sieht diese Entwicklung mit
großer Sorge der türkische
exiljournalist der Zeitung kumhyriet
mehrfach im Gefängnis musste aus seiner
Heimat fliehen er sieht
parallelen das erinnert mich an die
ersten Tage als bei uns die Demokratie
verloren ging enen an und dann merst
immer mehr Menschen die Medien angreifen
wenn man nicht auf ihrer Linie
litit Murat muss schon jetzt um sein
Leben fürchten er macht trotzdem weiter
unter besonderen
Sicherheitsbedingungen freie Meinung
muss ebeno oder so geschützt werden auch
dafür steht die erste Woche der
Pressefreiheit Preis für
Fernsehjournalismus der steht für
ausgezeichneten Journalismus in diesem
Jahr erhalten den Preis die Leiterin des
ARD Studios in Moskau in ROG und unser
ZDF Studioleiter aus Washington Elma
tesen die Jury würdigt ihn für seine
souveräne Sachkenntnis und den scharfen
Blick für die großen Zusammenhänge zudem
hat er eine bemerkenswerte Karriere
hingelegt sowohl auf diversen
scheidungsebenen der
zdfzentrale als auch im
Nachrichtenjournalismus und auch von uns
und vom gesamten Team herzlichen
Glückwunsch natürlich an beide und jetzt
geht's hier erstmal weiter mit den
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft und dir
Hanna trotz des wohnungsmangels in
Deutschland werden immer mehr
Bauprojekte in Deutschland stonniiert
das zeigt eine Umfrage des ifo Instituts
das von einem neuen Höchststand spricht
Valerie Haller
wie ist die Lage genau und was sind die
Gründe für diese Entwicklung also das
ifointitut sagt man habe seit der
Erhebung
1921 nichts Vergleichbares beobachtet
jedes fünfte der befragten Unternehmen
berichtet im August von abgesagten
Projekten fast die Hälfte meldet
Auftragsmangel und rund 12% sprechen von
Finanzierungsschwierigkeiten das ist der
höchste Wert seit über 30 Jahren ja die
Verunsicherung in der Branche ist riesig
für viele ren eren sich Ihre Bauvorhaben
nicht mehr oder sie sind schlicht nicht
finanzierbar aufgrund gestiegener
Baukosten und hoher Zinsen die Baukrise
ist auch ein Grund warum
Forschungsinstitute negativ auf unsere
Konjunktur blicken was heißt das denn
nun für das Ziel der Bundesregierung im
Jahr 400.000 neue Wohnungen zu bauen
also dieses Ziel ist ja schon in weiter
Ferne im kommenden Jahr könnte es aber
noch drastischer verfehlt werden die
Branche rechnet für die kommenden sech
Monate mehrheitlich mit geschäftsrück
Gängen zieht sich die Krise weiterhin
könnten noch mehr Baufirmen in
Schieflage geraten was das Erreichen der
Ziele natürlich weiter erschweren dürfte
dieses Jahr werden schätzungsweise
240.000 Wohnungen gebaut mit der großen
delle aber rechnet die Bauindustrie dann
im kommenden Jahr vielen Dank Valerie
nach
Frankfurt in Berlin ist am Abend der
Deutsche Gründerpreis verliehen worden
eine Auszeichnung für besonders
innovative Geschäftsideen im Bereich
Startups gewannen die Gründer von
friendly Catcher ihre Software schützt
Webseiten vor Bots und Spam komplett im
Hintergrund ohne das bekannte Bildchen
anklicken und somit
barrierefrei direkt nach dem heute
journal werden Preisträger und
nominierte des deutschen gründerpreises
dann ausführlich vorgestellt sehr schöne
laut um die Touristenmassen zu begrenzen
die wenedig jedes Jahr besuchen hat die
Lagunenstadt beschlossen dass
Tagesbesucher künftig einen Eintritt von
5 € Zahlen müssen allerdings zunächst
nur an 30 ausgewählten Tagen im Jahr an
denen erfahrungsgemäß besonders viele
Touristen kommen die genauen Daten sind
noch nicht bekannt die neue Gebühr soll
ab dem Frühjahr 2024 erhoben werden und
gilt für das historische
Zentrum es gibt aktuelle
Unwetterwarnungen des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes vor schweren Gewittern
mit teils extrem heftigem im stark Regen
und Hagel in Teilen von Niedersachsen
Nordrhein-Westfalen Hessen rheinandpfalz
und Bayern bereits im Laufe des Tages
gab es Unwetter über dem Westen
Deutschlands im reinlandfelsischen Worms
verwandelten Hagelschauer die Stadt in
eine Winterlandschaft auf der nahen A61
kam der Verkehr zeitweise zum Erliegen
zudem wurde im Münsterland durch
Starkregen die A2 überflutet was für
eine stundenlange Vollsperrung sorgte
und jetzt zum Fußball das erste
Testspiel der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft nach der Entlassung
von Hansi Flick stand heute Abend an
Gegner Frankreich auf der Trainerbank
vorübergehend Rudi Föller und das Spiel
endete vor wenigen Minuten mit einer
Überraschung 2:1 für
Deutschland ja ein sagen wir mal
schlechtes bis unsensibles Händchen
hatte der DFB ja beim Timing des
flickrauswurfs musste der Verband die
Trennung vom Bundestrainer ausgerechnet
in den letzten Minuten des WM
basketballfals veröffentlichen na ja gut
vielleicht haben sie ja aus des
Interesse das historische Finale ganz
einfach nicht gesehen Millionen andere
dagegen schon und so sind die Basketball
WM Helden aus dem Schatten des Fußballs
herausgetreten und hoffen nun dass das
auch nach ihrer Rückkehr aus Manila so
bleibt Markus
wolsffer um 10:47 Uhr knallen die Korken
champagnadusche zwischen den Frankfurter
Wolkenkratzern ganz s sie angekommen und
er der beste unter den Gipfelstürmern
Kapitän
MVP Player Dennis Schröder cool
geblieben reif geworden im mehr der
Mikrofone verschwindet er fast es dürfte
eine Genugtuung für den Braunschweiger
sein der schon lange mehr Respekt und
Aufmerksamkeit fordert für den
Basketball in Deutschland das
Erfolgsrezept seiner Mannschaft
egal was wir gemacht haben ob wir essen
gegangen sind zusammen wir die gleichen
Sachen
an manche Leute
denken nicht dazu aber wie gesagt wir
haben unsere Teamchemie so aufgebaut von
Tag 1 und ich glaube das hat man auch
gesehen dass wir wirklich als teamiert
haben Leistungswille Teamgeist
Leidenschaft der Kanadier Gordon Herbert
hat mit einer Mischung aus erfahrenen
und jungen Spielern eine Sensation
geschafft acht Spiele acht Siege vor
vier Jahren noch in der Vorrunde
ausgeschieden heute
Weltmeister das ist die beste Mannschaft
die ich je trainiert habe die beste
Gruppe von Leuten eine unfassbare
Leistung was wir abgeliefert haben die
Basketballer alles geben für den Erfolg
bis zur
Erschöpfung Erschöpfung kann auch anders
aussehen wenn der Sport eine Metapher
für den Zustand einer Gesellschaft ist
für ihr Potenzial und ihre Erfolge dann
sah es zuletzt nicht gut aus die
Fußballer ein Schatten ihrer selbst
Dauerkrise und Stagnation Anspruch und
Wirklichkeit zwei Welten der Sieg der
Basketballer Balsam für die geschundene
Fanseele ehrlich fin ich super to dass
es mal wieder von Deutschland was kommt
weil alles andere hat ja nicht geklappt
aber das hat geklappt der Soziologe
Robert gugutzer warnt davor die
Basketballer mit Erwartungen zu
überfrachten gerade weil keiner mit
ihnen gerechnet hatte sei das Wunder
möglich gewesen gleich wohl dort wo in
Deutschland viel Basketball gespielt
wird könne sich eine Art regionaler
stolz entfalten der wmtitel als
erlösungsmoment für eine müde
Gesellschaft das ist ja so so ein ganz
intensives sich spüren und dabei sein im
Hier und Jetzt sein nicht gestern oder
morgen diese kollektiven Gefühle die da
frei werden die auch ausleben zu dürfen
das sind schon Momente wo wo eine
Integration eine Gemeinschaftsgefühl
entsteht im nächsten Jahr sind die
Olympischen Spiele die Basketballer dann
in der ungewohnten Favoritenrolle sie
wollen weiter Vorbild sein und
Deutschlands sportliche Zukunft
mitgestalten von echten Helden zu einem
der sich selbst gern als epischen Helden
sieht Elon Musk mit
251 Milliarden Dollar reichstermann der
Welt Gründer von Tesla SpaceX zudem seit
fast einem Jahr Besitzer von Twitter
also der Kurznachrichtendienst der jetzt
ja x heißt x übrigens sein
lieblingsbuchstabe selbst eines seiner
elf Kinder hat er so genannt aber wie
tickt der 52-Jährige der aus seinem
Asberger Syndrom kein Geheimnis macht
wie lebt er was will er worum geht's ihm
seine Biografie die heute erschienen ist
gibt ein bisschen Aufschluss Claudia
Bates hat sie nicht nur gelesen sondern
auch mit dem Autoren gesprochen der mask
zwei Jahre lang begleitet
hat Elon Musk besessen und genial
größenwahnsinniger oder Weltenretter
masks Kindheit in Südafrika ist geprägt
von Gewalt er wird geschlagen er schlägt
der Schein trügt Erniedrigung ist Teil
der Erziehung als er Krankenhaus reif
geprügelt wird stellt sich der Vater auf
die Seite des Angreifers mask erzählt
ich musste eine Stunde lang daastehen
während er mich anschrie mich einen
Schwachkopf nannte und mir erklärte ich
wäre einfach nichts
wert was daraus entstand ist eine Person
die das Drama sucht und Drama und Sturm
mit Liebe verbindet er ist rig vbereit
und kennt keine Angst aber er ist auch
jemand bei dem wie bei seinem Vater die
Stimmung wechseln kann diese Dämonen
Rasseln in seinem Kopf die Dämonen der
Kindheit die aber auch Teil seines
Antriebs
sind
isxson schreibt von einem oft albernen
kindmann vor allem aber hat mask eine
Mission er will nicht weniger als die
Menschheit retten elektroautos sind
seine Antwort auf den Klimawandel
SpaceX soll die Menschen in die Tiefen
des Weltalls bringen für den Fall dass
die Erde nicht zu retten ist ich will
den marß besiedeln meine Lebensaufgabe
ist es aus der Menschheit eine
multiplanetare Zivilisation zu machen
musks maßmission wirkt für Biograf isxon
wie der Versuch nach Hause
zurückzukehren man wäre nicht völlig
entsetzt wenn er sich das Hemd vom lei
Risse und man sehen könnte dass er
keinen Nabel hat und nicht von diesem
Planeten stammt Musk Kritiker Galloway
dagegen spricht schlicht von einem
Gottkomplex wir suchen nicht mehr die
Religion um eine Lehre zu füllen
stattdessen schauen wir auf große
Erfinder denn Technologie ist wie
Religion mystisch und vermag
unglaubliches Leute glauben mask wenn er
etwas tut auch wenn es irrational ist
wir meinen er spielt Schach aber
vielleicht spielt er nur
Dame dabei ist es kein Spiel Ex vormals
twitter ist eine der
Kommunikationsplattformen als Verfechter
einer absoluten Meinungsfreiheit gibt
mask auch Lügnern und Hetzern eine Bühne
seine Starling Satelliten bringen
Internet in die Welt auch an die Front
im ukrainekrieg sie sind dort
mitentscheidend für Sieg oder Niederlage
diese Konzentration von macht wird in
der Biografie nicht kritisch
beleuchtet die Gesellschaft hat schon
eine Menge Schiedsrichter Anwälte die
sagen das solltest Du vielleicht nicht
tun ich würde sagen insgesamt ist die
Balance zu stark in Richtung der
Regulierer gekippt der Schiedsrichter
und zu wenig in Richtung der
Innovatoren ja Musk sei genial aber
ebenso gefährlich meint Kritiker Scott
Galloway es gibt eine gesunde Skepsis
gegenüber seiner Macht ein Gefühl dass
er sich an Normen nicht hält und man ihm
nicht vertrauen kann ich denke er wird
eine der grundlegendsten Lektionen der
menschlichen Geschichte zementieren das
Macht korrumpiert
die Biografie nimmt uns mit auf eine
Reise zu der schroffen Klippe auf der
Elon Musk ständig steht und wir
beobachten atemlos in welche Richtung er
geht kreativer Wahnsinn auf zwei Beinen
wir sagen an dieser Stelle danke fürs
zuschauen und auch fürs Mitdenken und
gegen 0:45 Uhr meldet sich dann hier
Gundula Gause mit unserem heute journal
Update das war's von uns machen sie es
gut wo auch immer sie sind tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend schauen wir noch mal auf die
Unwetter die heute von Frankreich
herangezogen sind das waren ja schon
wirklich heftige besonders in
Nordrhein-Westfalen aber auch im Süden
Deutschlands das schauen wir uns genauer
an was in in vergangenen 6 Stunden
passiert ist sie se sehen hier diese
Blitze sie sehen auch sehr viel Regen
besonders im Westen sie sehen auch hier
über dem rheinmineebiet und sie sehen
auch dass jetzt in der vergangenen
Stunde die kräftigsten Gewitter hier im
Nordwesten also z.B rund um Köln oder
Aachen nachgelassen haben aber hier sind
noch kräftige Gewitter unterwegs das
bedeutet Hag das bedeutet Überschwemmung
es bedeutet auch sehr viel Regen 40 l
pro quadr inmer einer Stunde sind
möglich und diese Unwetter werden im
Laufe der Nacht weiter nach Nordosten
ziehen dann wird vor allen Dingen der
Starkregen das Problem sein aber nicht
nur hier im Westen und in der Mitte und
im Norden Deutschlands hat es gewittert
sondern in den vergangenen 3 Stunden
auch am Alpenrand diese Zelle ist hier
entlang der Alpen gezogen die wird jetzt
aber immer mehr in sich zusammenfallen
und hier in Niederbayern oder auch in
Ostsachsen werden sie von den Gewittern
dieser Nacht gar nichts mitbekommen die
Temperaturen sinken auf 18 bis 11° und
steigen morgen auf 18 bis 24° in der
lausit sind es 26° morgen ziehen die die
Regenfälle dann ostwärts ab und am
längsten regnet und gewittert es noch in
Süddeutschland und dann wird es von Tag
zu Tag wieder mehr in Richtung
Spätsommer geben am Samstag liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen schon wieder bei 22
bis
28° guten Abend